[Music]
chip and Joanna Gaines welcome baby
number five so you think my chances as
you would say number five there's a
chance the fixer-upper stars joked about
having a fifth child while chatting with
et in October and on Saturday they
announced the arrival of their new
addition son crew games tip took to
Twitter with the exciting news writing
the game crew is now one stronger ten
beautiful toes and ten beautiful fingers
all accounted for and Big Mama is doing
great and a few hours later Joanna
shared a series of sweet photos
featuring the proud parents and their
new adorable little guys along with the
caption our baby boy crew Gaines is here
and we couldn't be more in love he made
an unexpected and speedy entrance into
the world two and a half weeks early
which is fitting given he was a sweet
surprise from day one the mama four also
instagrams this heartwarming snap of her
other kiddos anxiously waiting to meet
their new brother riding one of my
favorite pics a friend showed me after
crew was born they just grow up so fast
and so it's been crazy the whole
makeover couple are also parents two
eight-year-old m EK nine-year-old do 11
year old ella and 13 year old Drake
[Music]
[Applause]